alors bonjour à la planète tout le monde
vous entend bonjour je suis là vous avez
de l'énergie que vous allez manger vos
votre sandwich ce matin c'est tous en
forme
oui mais gêné au long d'une gaine qui a
pas pris de vacances
moi non moi j'en ai un peu j'en avais
pris trop alors autant à table en chêne
du côté de la technique web notre
webmestre cette semaine marie jobin qui
est du secteur français de radio canada
international
paloma martinez qui joue sur toutes les
patinoires ici rci une collecte de
travail et ce l'est et alice chantal
jedem qui est de notre collègue depuis
plusieurs années je pense que j'ai vu
des articles de vous qui devra mandat
oui c'est vrai c'était sûr à la radio
six premières alors aujourd'hui vous
connaissez le règlement il ya un jeu à
un jeu vous gagnez des points et un
grand prix de participation à la fin
d'émission
celui de mon estime et ensuite pendant
cette émission il ya un invité mystère
qui s'y glisse et pour devenir looten
l'émission vous savez comment ça
commence avec une vidéo
seulement ça qui marche très bien et
puis on va regarder tous ensemble cette
vidéo est ce que est ce que vous pouvez
allumer l'écran numéro 38 ce que ce soit
si on voit les vidéos c'est pas possible
parce que nos internautes peuvent voir
la vidéo mais nous pas alors c'est celle
de deux fini on va lui donner quelques
1000 internautes de deviner c'est quoi
si j'ai écouté avant de devenir le sujet
parce qu'on n'est pas prêt tout à fait
on a fait un gros sujet les bélugas
cette semaine vous y travaillez chantal
oui tout à fait avec un article très
très drôle sur un jeune homme de 16 ans
qui a chassé tout un tout un bep lucas
tout une baleine à tout juste 16 ans et
qui a enflammé la toile avec son
histoire
et puis moi je travaille un espagnol
cette semaine
et puis c'est drôle parce qu'on
discutait juste avant d'aller à l'aude
ou qu'on parle du même sujet mais deux
endroits différents au canada moi aussi
je parle d'une chasse à la baleine mais
dans le nord du canada
ainsi c'est dans le bon tu as eu loin
ses alouettes
mais ce que je sus que je ne connais pas
le nom en français de cette baleine en
particulier mais on l'appelle la baleine
boréale ou beau et doux et un anglais et
puis cela fait plusieurs années que
cette communauté des cadeaux et des
forfaits formi charb et n'arrivait pas à
pouvoir chasser la baleine parce que
malgré l'autorisation du gouvernement
ont ils sont pas toujours très enviée
pour exceptionnel
enfin ce qu'est la balance approche pas
assez ou c'est trop difficile de la
chasse et dont mais cette fois ci
c'était vraiment content parce qu'ils
sont réussi à chasser sainte-rose
baleines qui va alimenter aussi
plusieurs communes et maire pendant la
mène le produit de la chasse il faut
comme le redistribue au sein de la
communauté
donc chacun de revoir ça n'est pas de
l'iti morcenais de la baleine exactement
donc ça peut durer à plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois parfois dépendamment des
communautés et puis c'est une grande
fierté pour le peuple du nord du canada
vu donc le peuple inuit donc j'ai
entendu en fait vous savez la cilicie
news en anglais le service anglais de
radio-canada à une aussi une équipe en
inuktitut qui est la langue du nord du
canada
et puis j'ai vu là là
la reporter raconter la chasse parce
qu'il est allé interviewer les chasseurs
avec des chansons qui avaient presque
certains c'était magnifique
besson oui exactement toute l'énergie
pour aller chasser la baleine je pense
qu'il lui donnait y amener sa sagesse pu
écouter on a fait on a fait une émission
sur les baleines l été dernier
et puis vous faire retrouver sans les
hanches et des émissions toutes les
émissions vous cliquez sur l'onglet sur
la page première d'accueil de radio
canada international ai trouvé ça je
pensais tout le mois de juillet de l'an
dernier aujourd'hui nouvelle émission
nouveau thème c'est pas celui des
baleines
on est prêt à plonger d'accord vidéo
cinq images on y va et puis dès que vous
sentez que vous avez vous êtes sur la
piste du sujet vous un vous n'hésitez
pas vous pouvez y aller avant votre
collègue alors tout le monde autour de
la planète joue jusqu'à cinq images et
ça y est ça commence avec ce qu'est ce
que c'est une grosse structure
ça ressemble à la ronde un jeu une foire
du jeu ouais les nouvelles grandes roues
un moment c'est pas la 9e grand droit
on est un peu des montgolfières où il y
en a beaucoup
cette quatrième image 5e images semblent
se serait saint jean sur le richelieu
mais encore quel est le thème de
l'émission aujourd'hui
vous êtes vous pour garder
l'international de montgolfières de
saint-jean-sur-richelieu et y est
presque
y a plus qu à me parler mais on va
amener nos auditeurs pour leur montrer
où ça se trouve c'est près de montréal
saint jean sur richelieu voyez sur la
carte
oui on va agrandir la carte voilà où ça
se trouve à peu près moi je dirais 35
minutes quarante minutes de route de
montréal non loin de la frontière
américaine où aller voir en pointillés
au bas de la carte ça voilà ça montre
c'est les états unis c'est là où se
trouve l'oncle tronçon vers le sud est
c'est dans le sud quelque chose
c'est ça la gauche
écoutez on va montrer des images de
l'international de montgolfières de
saint jean sur richelieu parce notre
thème aujourd'hui on a des belles images
à vous montrer filmé par une équipe de
radio canada vidéo numéro deux et
pendant qu'on regarde ça ensemble je
vous donne un bref historique vous avez
une idée de combien ça fait combien
d'années qu'on qu'on a ce genre
d'événement international 25 25 tout
proche d'être tout près tout près oui
[Rires]
c'est pour ce qu'elle est c'est moi de
rester sinon vous laisser rouler les
images pour qu'on les voit ce sont des
images qui roule il suffit de laisser
aller pour qu'elles veulent c'est
amusant voici des gens qui ont des
aérostiers je pense qu'on les appelle
moi je fais pas ça va mais je pense que
ce sera le terme et 1984
la première édition c'est le plus grand
festival au canada il y en a un plus
grand dans la francophonie 7 en france
est le plus grand au monde
on va aller faire un tour un peu plus
tard à cet endroit mais pour le moment
ça se passe chez nous ça dépend des
années 105 100 à 125 150 équipes qui se
relaient pour monter dans le ciel
et c'est un événement familial parce que
c'est pas juste des opa long qui monte
êtes vous déjà monté sur le ballon comme
ça je pense qu'on me retrouverais région
mais moi d'ailleurs je voulais pas vous
poser la question vaut cependant qu'elle
n'a pas en question à ses missions c'est
vous est-ce que vous iriez comme ça dans
une nacelle ces nouvelles enquêtes sur
votre maison ça pour être plaisant tout
à fait oui pouvoir garder la terre
autrement c'est pas moi j'ai ma licence
de pilote d'avion en jpy les torts la
nerd je sais pas si ce parce que le
super lot éclate mais on pense pas cette
dimension
la dimension ludique oui profession mais
moi j'aime bien les ailes
alors si le moteur l'âge on fait
toujours planer oui si simple à non
j'imagine un madani tu imagines ce à
dessein train qui main sur les fils
électriques
[Rires]
il fonce à l'aéroport de saint-hubert
modérée au port de saint jean puis il ya
des champs partout autour alors si il ya
un problème avec la météo ils peuvent
atterrir sans se faire de mal non ça
c'est des images tournées au matin un
oui parce que si je passe on peut dire à
tes rires je pense qu'on peut dire a
beau dire à bompas trouver plus beau mon
plus beau plus poétique cebu abalone
hier et puis que c'est quand même assez
récent nous on nous on est jeune alors
nous on y en ait mené avec ça mais ceux
qui sont plus vieux là qui ont qui ont
disons 60 ans ils connaissent pas ça
vraiment c'est à la fin des années 50
qu'ils ont utilisés ils ont découvert
les fibres synthétiques qui permettait
donc de mettre du propane c'était plus
résistants donc on va aller plus haut
plus loin plus en plus sécuritaire et
c'est devenu vraiment populaire donc cet
aspect retiennent ce moment là que c'est
ça dont on commence à voir ces gros
ballons dans le ciel et des collections
de gros ballons et est ce que vous savez
pourquoi ça vole histoire scientifique
parce que j'étais chaud
le professeur c'est archimède qui est à
l'auteur de tout ça c'est connu c'est un
truc qui déplace des quelque chose ça
déplace on ne change pas ça le principe
beaucoup d'air chaud vous savez
yg on fait ça avec de l'air chaud ou du
propane votre avec du bois pas venir je
n'ai aucune idée saluons va faire chaud
les particules prennent de l'expansion
sans sam ans parce que le reste de l'air
autour
et puis danse je pense qu'on est la
montée ça se dirige dans les airs il ya
quelque chose dans ces pages où c'était
un ballon qu'on dirige non il ya
quelqu'un qui tire avec une poussière
depuis le sol comme ça non tout est
parti du sel je pense qu'on aurait
besoin d'un spécialiste expliqué et
c'est sa faune si cette personne s'en
vient rassurez vous pour le moment c'est
la première manche notre jeu de la
grosse boule du savoir en revient au
studio me lâche nos boules et ça vaut 20
points on lâche la boule une grosse
boule jouée au quai s'inquiète un studio
est aussi grosse ça ouais tous ceux qui
jouent avec nous chaque semaine le savez
elle est toujours là cette boule c'est
pas c'est pas parce qu'aider on parle d
donc on a une boule en sus de cette
semaine donc 20 points pour ce prime
cette première manche et un à trois ans
l'émission
voici le préambule de la question
référendaire il est généralement admis
que la montgolfière est inventée par les
frères montgolfier
je pense joseph michel et jean qui
tiennent était au xvème siècle xvième
siècle xviie siècle au xviiie siècle
17e xviie siècle c'est bien donc on a
mis la table à l'iss vous voulez ajouter
que je voulais depuis déplacer la ciat
tout qu'est ce que vous faites avec ça
j'avoue que c'est une histoire que j'ai
eu à lire dans un petit livre avec mon
fiston
mais j'arrive pas à me situer par
rapport à la c6 mènerait m'aventurer
dans le xviiie siècle c'est le siècle
des lumières
non c'est bien et qu'elle est et reste
le plus aura plus qu elle a rapproché le
siècle puis rapprocher c'était le 18e
temps derrière 18e 18e agirait avec la
proposition
c'est la partie du xviiie siècle qu'on a
fait toutes sortes de découvertes
scientifiques et techniques
tu me dis que ça a peut-être servi à
quelque chose
c'est avait de l'intuition et vous êtes
des lumières 20 points chacun
c'est pas autour de 800 noms 1783 un
petit peu avant à condé couper la tête à
6800 on est rendu au 19e siècle
d'accord mais quand même ça s'est passé
un 19 septembre
la confusion des noms mais bon on est
monté à 490 mètres de hauteur sont en
piste et c'est hallucinant oui je sais
plus haut par 3.3 dans et autour de 1200
1300 vous avez fait des études en
mathématiques et victoire dont je
parlais tantôt avec un personnage
central charlemagne way avec son ballon
dirigeable
il se rendait en amérique du sud avec sa
copine je sais plus et elisabeth quelque
chose comme ça on est en amour mon fils
me dira mais je crois que c'est au
xviiie siècle écoutés
cette semaine c'est la première fois que
ça nous arrive je pense en un an et demi
pas d'entrevue skype
il ya une entrevue une interview et
mystère mais pas d'entrevue skype
puisque il ce festival international est
un petit peu bon il reconnu non on nous
a promis une invitée elle s'est désistée
à la dernière minute et vous savez
comment c'est les tout le monde était
parti en l'air alors là c'est très
sérieux mais oui c'est très sérieux
j avec une personne pour accorder des
entrevues et malheureusement elle est
partie alors quand elle redescendra elle
exactement ça il ya une heure et demie
j'ai appris ça donc nous on sait on est
très professionnel on s'est dit on a
évidemment des spécialistes que nous
avons déjà interview à 1,6 par rapport à
ce festival est rassurant puisque après
tout il ya radio canada international et
il ya le festival de montgolfières
international de saint jean sur le
richelieu communauté d'esprit ici alors
voici nous avons parlé avec madame
marie-claude beauvais convaincante dans
quelques instants qui est la
vice-présidente marketing de
l'international des montgolfières de
saint jean sur le richelieu dans une
toute récente édition et elle nous parle
2 non seulement des montgolfières mais
des visiteurs des simples spectateurs
plus de 350000 attendue en ce moment
même
et voici donc cette entrevue réalisée
par didier hoti et pendant qu'on
l'écouté on vous présente d'autres
images pour nous inspirer d'autres
images poétiques de ce festival des
montgolfières notre vidéo numéro 3 donc
nous accueillons les pilotes de partout
à travers le monde dont nous avons des
pilotes de montgolfières donc le pilote
possède sa propre montgolfière nous
l'accueillons les pilotes proviennent
autant du canada des états unis du
brésil de l'europe de l'australie
dangereux manque d'un peu partout à
travers le monde et parmi les 125
montgolfières nous avons également des
formes spéciales donc ce sont des
éléments volière qui représenterait
d'image d'une girafe un hippocampe
moutons clown etc
ces personnes dont qui apporte la
montgolfière est ce qu'elles paient ces
personnes là pour participer au festival
ou bien la participation est plutôt
encouragé gratuite mais évidemment nous
voulons bien accueillir ses pilotes là
qui proviennent d'un peu partout à
travers le monde donc nous nous faisons
évidemment un devoir de les accueillir
deux lits nous rire évidemment de pays
pour les nuitées donc de vraiment les
zhu zhu pets pour qu'ils aient envie de
revenir
allez après c'est une activité familiale
donc le public visé 6 la famille c'est
vraiment la famille donc nous avons des
activités vraiment pour les tout petits
mais également pour les adolescents et
évidemment pour les adultes donc nous
ouvrons 2010 à 23h30 et donc les
activités sont en continu tout au long
de la journée et les envolées de
monrovia prennent part pour elle
à 18h le soir certains soirs nous avons
ce que nous appelons des lieux magiques
donc les montgolfières gonfle reste au
sol et s'illumine tels des lanternes
chinoises dont un magnifique spectacle
en soirée
parce qu'évidemment le feu des brûlures
permettent aux montgolfières de déployer
leur belle couleur et danser
très très festif au temps des musiques
très rythmées
alors voilà c'est quand même des petites
explications qui viennent de
marie-claude beauvais vice président
marketing de l'international des
montgolfières de saint jean sur le
richelieu talk interview et dans une
récente édition par notre collègue
didier hoti on est prêtes pour notre
toit deuxième manche je vous dise et 30
points et c'est c'est facile c'est très
facile c'est jamais facile j'ai
l'habitude des questions compliquées
mais c'est facile d'accord à wassit jeu
de la grosse boule deuxième manche 30
points le record du monde de décollage
en ligne donc au décollage de pas comme
des avions mais déconnage tout un groupe
le déconnage en ligne c'est le langage
des spécialistes et collages de décalage
de quoi mieux pour les montgolfières
[Rires]
vous êtes vraiment des journalistes des
esprits aux journalistes alors c'est
donc ça s'est réalisé le record du monde
de nouveaux records en 2015 y en avait
eu précédemment en 2013
vrai ou faux c'est en france qu'a eu
lieu ce record du monde
vrai ou faux il a eu la france et bien
d'autres pays ces peuplements beaucoup
de pays comprenant mieux que les ballons
ça fait le tour du monde en 80 jours
samedi que la france avait le festival
des montgolfières le plus grande
allemande donc je dirais vous allez dire
vrai oui pour 30 points vous êtes dire
vrai oui est ce que quelqu'un qui veut
dire faux moi oui j'ai dit faux et vous
maryse vous dites souvent j'hésitais ce
que je pourrais prendre des drm
malheureusement il faut choisir moi je
l'exercé com/indices faux ah là là c'est
vrai parce qu'on a on n'a pas d'autres
éléments pour vous permettre 50 % de
succès si 50% de chances de succès 20.30
points 20 points c'est traître c'est
comme jasper dit vous êtes tous
participé à la finale veut alors est
tout autant dire encore tous à manger
quand je parle d'un sujet j'aime
toujours aller un peu plus loin voire
bon par curiosité personnelle pas
professionnel
alors des personnages et oui ça va
jusqu'à quelle hauteur on peut monter
comme ça en ballon et vous mais jusqu'à
temps qu'on manque pas d'exiger pour
respirer parce qu'alors on n'aurait rien
à brûler j'imagine non plus bas il ya
des gens qui mentent avec des masques
oui mais là le problème c'est qu'avec le
gaz on brûle l'air on réchauffe l'air
localement 6 à pudeur ouais mais c'est
parce qu'on a un en altitude le gaz
apprendre plus d'expérience ion parce
que moi une molécule autour du ballon
pour faire de la compression utilise le
même gain jusqu'à 400 m 400 m et 400 m
amos il est beaucoup beaucoup plus
simple d'avoir un tel personnage à la
télé de reportages de ballon qui était
vraiment très très très long je vais
vous proposer de regarder la vie numéro
cas tout le monde ensemble
vous allez me dire à peu près quelle
altitude on se trouve la vidéo
le flash fasse attention mal à livrer
des secrets comme ça si facilement 4000
kwh à 4000 met donc on est à peu près de
4600 donc on est en reprise 15 bénitier
c'est ça même points 5 3 points après 3
3 points 3 ça se passe en france les
champions mondiaux de montgolfière avec
les records tout ça ils ont ri porte pas
de masque et c'est au dessus
ddd un autre alors j'étais parce que
sinon il avait froid mais vous l'avez
dit en temps mais j'ai entendu 404 voilà
c'est pas leur corse à 4002 quelque
chose non non c'est pas le record alors
maintenant parce qu'elles vendent allons
spécialement dit que c'est allé beaucoup
plus haut c'est ça il y en a une couple
en fait il ya eu un monsieur qui
s'appelait je pense c'est moi j'essaie
de me souvenir mon sens gardner quelque
chose mon google à l'origine heures de
sa fait le tour du monde cette histoire
c'est un 2013
et puis il avait été obligé de mettre un
masque puis il était monté avec une le
ballon l'avait propulsé pratiquement
dans la stratosphère m'accorde
ça a été très médiatisé mais regardez la
numéro 5 ça s'est passé deux ans plus
tard et c'est vraiment le record du
monde en ballon
c'est un autre américain l'histoire n'a
pas été couverts par les médias
pratiquement à l'américaine et en 1957
garantir des images d'une vidéo
présentée dans le cadre des conférences
ted
voyez le cosmonaute là parce qu'à cette
attitude là il est il va montrer à 44
1041 1419 m il va il va prendre deux
heures un peu plus de deux heures à
monter comme ça tiré par une part le
ballon le voile qui décolle et savent
donc de un peu deux heures à monter il
dit que c'est extrêmement paisible et
les gens de la conférence le ballon est
complètement fermé alors c'est pas la
même technologie
quelques ballons ordinaire alors le
voilà que cet homme c'est un champion
c'est un ancien directeur ingénieur en
informatique vice président de google en
ça vice président argent et puis ça
alors là il quand tu la montée ça va bon
le jeu j'ai accéléré les images parce
qu'on a quand même que une demi heure
d'émission regarder le nom de
montgolfières oui ça non je soupçonne
qu'ils aient un parachute oui doit avoir
bien un parachute regarde et qu'on
allait rapport à l'air tout petit
oui c'est intéressant là il atteint
astres la stratosphère sur le pont de
québec de voir son équipe comme à la
nasa qui le suit de près et on va lui
donner le signal bientôt ça y est tu as
atteint le record c'est assez tu en as
fait assez d'essence
tu va redescendre le voilà qui s'apprête
est redescendu va être il va précipiter
vers le sol
oui il va se détacher est-ce qu'il va de
santé alors voila voila il serait prêt à
prendre sa décision fatidique
j'espère qu'il en arrache est il à une
fusée parachute
j'ai vu ça aujourd'hui je peux pas vous
présenter ça fait pas partie du sujet
directement on prend un essai
alors le voilà ils y prennent c'est
comme un astronaute dans l'espace est
tout à fait il n'y a pas grande
différence
est ce qu'ils sont ou pas ça prend du
temps
monde ça y est non huit cent mille par
heure maintenir un point si ça vous
donne le kilométrage d'accord mais en
mètre par seconde 357 m je ne sais pas
je pense que c'est une auteure regarder
le reste c'est réglo allait comme c'est
vous qui êtes une pilote d'avion a nommé
à leurs noms mais la wii avec les vieux
parachute
ça s'est super bien avec les vieux c'est
un exploit souligné tu parlais il ya
perdu vous nous parler un peu plus tôt
de cette oeuvre
ben je suis dit qu il soit entre
collègues mais vous vous nous parlez
donc de cette personne de charles mobbs
oui mais c'est un personnage imaginaire
dans un livre pour enfants mais c'est
pas de vue non celui qui a sauté à sans
parachute d'une montgolfière en 2015
non non il avait aussi quelque chose
son constat menti alors le reste j'ai
oublié ce qui se passe avec 18 millions
de vues sur youtube vous irez voir 118
millions chercher en ti sours en
parachute fou d'aller trouver et il est
je vous dit écoutez il a sauté avec deux
autres gars qui avait eu des parachutes
et ils l'ont ils ont été le récupérer il
va traiter
ouais ouais il est maligne et ben c'est
un c'est un club qui fait des actes fous
comme ça et plus de vue qu'ils ont plus
d'argent ils font quoi ils vont suivre
avec des avions et le les gens qui sont
dans les avions
l'avion va se rapprocher de personnes
kita chute libre pour le ramasser cas de
nécessité
c'est particulier non moi j'ai des
injustes à regarder les images
je démens j'ai déjà mal au coeur ça
donne le vertige sa part évalué main ont
l'intention de montrer beaucoup
maintenant regarder cet hymne son
reportage de radio canada international
s'est il ya trois ans la même année où
il a le fouet sauter en parachute
c'est un jeune homme qui s'est envolé
sur 10 km tirées par une germes de
ballons remplis d'hélium
je pense qu'il ya 23 ans quelque chose
comme ça puis je pense qu'ils voulaient
étonné sa future du ciné combien de
ballons ils étaient d'hélium comme ça
juste à quelques pages 10 et une
centaine oui on peut le lire
oui 110 ben moi je le vois c'est
beaucoup plus bas il avait ses habitudes
c'est toujours bien de pouvoir virnot
ancien reporter c'est pour ça qu'on a
une chronique sur la page de time qui
s'appelle fouiller dans nos agences
samedi ce ballon bon vous êtes prêts
pour la dernière question autres je dis
cela c'est beau c'est jouer en ce moment
oui ben 30 20 alors c'est très difficile
tant de questions j'ai encore c'est
difficile cinq mois en général qui gagne
à ce jeu
je gagne jamais alors troisième manche
50 points pression barométrique principe
d'archimède et propriétés des gaz à
différentes températures
voilà qui détermine le volume d'air
qu'il faut souffler dans une
montgolfière pour qu'elle s'élance vers
le ciel
dans le cas d'un jeune homme à calgary
s'apprend 110 ballon on le sait on a le
calcul voici la question 36 g aux règles
au mètre cube
quel volume d'air faut-il souffler dans
le ballon le véritable ballon de la
moldau fier pour remporter une seule
personne les options j'imagine oui 50
mètres cube pop 150 mètres cubes ou 250
mètres cubes
mais lorsqu'on parle du volume une fois
que l'arrêt d'un ballon ou ce qu'on
utilise pour décoller du sol décollé du
sud et donc la présidence ne sais pas et
c'est quoi déjà 50 mètres cubes 150
mètres cubes 250 mètres que pour une
personne de corpulence ordinaire à
lessive ou bois je prendrai le juste
milieu
ça semble être un choix prudent
moi c'est moi je sais pas moi
scientifiquement je me dirais 50 parce
que lorsque ça prend du volume ouais ça
va habiter le ballon d'accord ah là là
alors je trois réponses fermes en aura
qu'un gagnant j'imagine d'accord alors
qui a répondu 250 mètres cubes 80 points
total ça varie de 250 mètres cubes dans
des conditions météorologiques très
favorables comme celles au canada à plus
de 24 mille mètres cubes pour les plus
grands de montgolfières qui peuvent
emporter 45 personnes ont parcouru le
monde à faire des 45 personnes mais là
pour une seule personne en question
j'élargis réponse pour donner plus
d'information possible après tout c'est
mon travail
une seule personne si vous voyez vous en
tirez avec 250
peut-être
c'est pas fini on peux continuer encore
quelques minutes
si les way d'accord ont valu les
reportages qu'on a fait cette semaine
j'ai pas tout prix on va regarder ce
qu'ils annonceront pas ça non c'est trop
bon la colombie-britannique qui brûlent
des canadiens de l'ouest suffoque une
nouvelle réalité qui est l'auteur de cet
article moi c'est sérieux c'est tout à
fait sérieux et ce qui est intéressant
c'est la deuxième année qu'il ya des
feux aussi important et pourquoi
réchauffement climatique mais on est
pris avec des arbres qui ont 30 ans 53
cents ans qui sont un petit livre dans
des conditions plus froides et qu'il a à
cause des éclairs à cause des phénomènes
météorologiques les éclairs mettre le
feu et là ça brûle et on a vu des images
saisissantes de la capitale albertaine
de calgary aussi à me donner calgary 5
aux britanniques
tout juste à côté à l'alberta est tout
juste à côté la sq à tshwane le manitoba
et là c'était pas fumer voyage d'ouest
en est
comme les grands courants et c'est ce
qui arrive d'accord je voulais justement
cette semaine ne travaille pas en
français mais en langue espagnole
couvert aussi les feux dé forêt en
colombie-britannique parce que il y a
des des brigades de pompiers qui
viennent de partout dans le monde dont
le mexique
donc il y à du mexique il ya autour de
380 pompiers qui sont venus exactement
mais il y a des états unis il ya
d'ailleurs aussi donc c'est vraiment un
cran c'est maïs intéressant qu'ils
viennent du mexique parce que quand on y
pense
les feux montent la côte ouest donc
mexique etats unis et canada sont
connectés pour par eddy sont habitués
son expertise on va aller vers un autre
reportage cette semaine celui effectué
par la fait plus qu'une mais là c'est la
question de alice les élections
générales au québec
cette annonce est disons
la campagne électorale va démarrer
bientôt dans quelques semaines je crois
c'est 23 23 et les élections c'est le
premier est donc le premier au top on a
coeur tout à fait et donc il ya cette
possibilité qui est offerte aux
personnes l'extérieur de la province de
pouvoir voter par anticipation et par la
poste et donc j'ai trouvé que c'était
important d'en parler pour les personnes
soient au courant qu'elles soient
sensibilisés alors si on est prisonnier
de la ville de toronto
on peut par exemple y bâtissant se
trouve à toronto son mât pas prisonnier
six anciens se trouve à toronto au
canada
si on est parti en voyage quelque part
on est pas privé de son droit de vote on
peut le faire en allant s'inscrit sur le
site internet car et puis on va recevoir
tous les documents nécessaires pour
pouvoir le faire
c'est je suis au courant que c'est une
c'est une pratique courante pour les
pour la france les extrêmes pas extra
patrie généalogistes c'est très beau je
trouve que ça donne une bonne idée de ce
qu'on veut dire aller mais pour les
québécois si je savais pas que c'était
possédait ce que ces nouveaux comme non
c'est pas nouveau c'est pas nouveau j'en
ai discuté avec une représentante
d'élections québec qui m'a dit c'est une
expérience qu'on veut renouveler parce
que ça apportait de mon résultat
donc c'est pas du tout nouveau et les
québécois le savent ils sont habitués à
cela fantastique
oui j'avais quelque chose à ajouter je
ne travaille pas avec vous mais j'ai été
chanceux parce que cette année il ya eu
deux sélections mixité et puis on a eu
les les votes pas par la poste ou six
mois j'avais pas un peu de ses systèmes
j'aurais voulu que ce soit de matisse et
et tout mais ça a très bien marché je
voudrais bien marché pour cette élection
présidentielle qui a eu lieu au mexique
la plupart des élections vont bien
tourner l'important c'est d'aller voter
sinon c'est à dire où je pense que notre
génération le sait maintenant
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à l'aise
d'être venu cette semaine toujours merci
à mes collègues est ce que la personne
qui dit vous devez venir n'y a pas de
règlement alors c'est on est à la merci
du bon vouloir de tous et chacun et du
de leurs horaires de travail
fermé ou pas des fois merci beaucoup à
l'iss l'invitation la porte est toujours
ouverte et je viendrai tout temps avec
plaisir oui on vous envoie un petit
ballon chercheurs sauf que je suis pas
prête à sauter dans les airs par exemple
je suis pas assez courageuse peut-être
maryse m'accompagnera où on le fait avec
un mail à plus tard
passons on nota le goût de le faire
alors merci d'avoir rebondi en studio ce
ne soit pas vous avez piloté comme un
champion bravo merci merci en fait celui
qui pilotait vraiment c'était herschel
notre web merci beaucoup rrc numéro 38
encore cette semaine pour les adieux
d'accord on est prêt oui à la semaine
proche